I'll be right back when they ever achi
wings hit me I can't wait til everyone
at home has that stuck in their [ __ ]
head it's gonna I start to shake I start
to quiver the things that people thought
were entertaining in like the 50s it's
so strange when you go back now watch
that stuff that was like that was almost
like sultry - back then you know that
she's like with her pen like this
innocent girl writing note what the [ __ ]
was she even writing down and then she's
she's gone you know oh just when the
piano man winks hit me like that's the
naughtiest [ __ ] of the day if I have a
time machine what I would love to do is
take like all these old folks that are
like in in the audience watching that
weren't even old folks at the time right
young people like in their 30s yeah
thought that was wonderful and put on
like a modern day mumble rapper like 20
people onstage with them
puffs and blood yeah you know drinking
[ __ ] lean and trap-trap transit yeah I
just abolish me give it a hobble to
booze but is it Bob who these people
just like yeah like the kid with the
hair the rainbow hair yeah what's his
[ __ ] name is he a mom or a per the
guy got beat up in New York he got
pistol-whipped right now allegedly yeah
I was just gonna say that's a that's
great promo yeah he might have punched
himself in the head because I saw a
photo online it didn't look like he got
why can't I think his name a friend of
mine was breaking up with her husband at
the time and they were screaming to yell
at each other and dude starts clawing at
himself start clawing to get him scratch
marks I'm saying that she was attacking
her ripped his clothes it called the
police
a guy did it so listen it's not outside
the realm of possibility though mumble
rapper took that [ __ ] docked himself
in the head told the security to call it
call the ambulance right away
and then went in this day and age people
are just doing anything to stay relevant
you stay relevant to get attention
they'll do anything well that's what
they that's what instagram has become
that's what the Internet has become it's
just become the way to be like huh it's
not necessarily what it's become but
it's certainly a venue for people that
don't have any other options it's big
works a lot of people make make actual
careers I'm just on Instagram but
there's people that like Kendrick
Lamar's not doing that
yeah he's [ __ ] yeah but no I'm saying
yeah he doesn't need that [ __ ] but he
doesn't need that [ __ ] but some people
do need that [ __ ] then they're tattooing
their face and mumble rap and pistol
whippin themselves face tattoo blows it
blows my mind do you know that Travis
Barker just got a new one
she's got a face tattoo it says blessed
where on his cheek oh we doin bro he's
just he's covered man yeah I see Aniyah
he's had his whole net I know I stole
all of his neck is done he's done his
head's done but he stopped at one point
right he doesn't he never did his face
yeah he's not no he's doing his face now
son his Instagram says blessed right
below his cheeks no who's the guy who
wrote always tired posted below post
Malone yeah above his eyebrow right
isn't it on his below eyebrow
somebody had a great meme of post Malone
in high school his high school yearbook
photo and they wrote pre Malone I
thought that was hilarious
[Laughter]